Este es el humo que dejó un ataque con
drones contra Moscú a primera hora de la
mañana
kiev trata de asustar a Rusia a los
rusos y llevar a cabo ataques contra
edificios residenciales Esta es una
Clara señal de actividad terrorista
Aunque más que en el ataque Estoy
preocupado por los esfuerzos por
provocar una respuesta de Rusia ese
Parece ser el objetivo nos están
provocando a hacer lo mismo dos heridos
y algunos edificios evacuados ya había
habido ataques en zonas fronterizas de
Rusia y Ucrania antes
Moscú había culpado a Jeff querer
atentar contra Vladimir Putin con un
dron derribado sobre el kremlin pero
este es el primer ataque contra
objetivos civiles en la capital rusa
crece el temor entre la población
me alegro
por casa pero estuvo bastante cerca pero
bueno era lógico era de esperar es todo
lo que puedo decir
por su parte recibió una tercera
ofensiva en 24 horas tras un ataque con
drones que dejó la muerte de una mujer
una decena de heridos y 20 evacuados
la casa temblaba por todas partes era
aterrador tenemos que quedarnos en los
refugios porque nunca se sabe dónde van
a caer los drones pero aguantamos
es el décimo séptimo ataque del mes de
mayo mientras desde el inicio de la
guerra hay cerca de 800 edificios
destruidos y más de 160 muertos en la
capital ucraniana
Putin necesita Ucrania sin ucranianos es
terrorismo todos por supuesto Están
preocupados por eso los dos rusos
quieren deprimir a nuestra gente pero en
lugar de depresión la gente está muy
enfadada
desde Rusia aseguran que es el ataque
más grave en Moscú desde la Segunda
Guerra Mundial mientras que Ucrania
habla de éxito Por la alta intercepción
de drones gracias a las defensas
antimisiles suministradas por Estados
Unidos